Maria's quick to tell people he's
actually a point guard and a to God's
body and he has a perfect with that nice
move Plus this nice match about Thomas
Webber great defenders smart spidery
with hours left ended time Wow
go go he's being told to go to the
basket you something that it doesn't
give up on the shot at all does it
Annie look at this strip ulis good
defense great effort by Murray not
stopping
now tomorrow morning let's go yes Marie
answers back to start the season and
then you come home and everything's up
who biorhythms off everything's tired
and done for him 17 points Lillard with
28 McCallum with 21 Turner's got 14 Oh
basket counts foul Jamal Murray 18
seconds to go
inbound play to Murray long range yes
well designed play how about we go
Nuggets briefly had the lead and 6463
Oh Mike Mike Malone turn to the mids it
started smiling and clapping then once
he's trying to get it inside I think he
got himself caught and he said let me
just get the meat I don't know what he
was thinking that's a kid that's not a
good shot daddy got a piece of that
[Applause]
Lexus drive of the game this but then
you can't fight over the players that
play before spin inside spin around
right before town this team's a
contender in the West no doubt about it
absolutely Wow Jamal Murray - and that
was a nasty crossover at the three-point
line Wow
Jamal Murray didn't realize that he had
this kind of explosion you you said he
did and I believe you now he got some
hops she's got to get more of these
finishes right here off the screen is
Murray gonna try to dunk it on somebody
right hand and switch to the left wait
watch this show right over the top hold
on a wheel back down Brett saw
reminiscent
[Music]
kalenna [ __ ] travel now born back to
her 34:20 yes
[Applause]
while Joe and I save four seconds Murray
pull it up let's it go yes
great double clutch - to breathe from
the corner go by Chris
there's a lot of there's healed for the
hometown crowd motion right here I think
would shoot into Bernie Birds yes
big shot 68 you're watching altitude
sports your home for Nuggets basketball
all season electric would pull the
trigger
Murray who wants to pull the trigger
coming in
but tribulation to the whole Lexus much
of Albury watch this around the corner
[Music]
Scott Hastings confident as it needs the
stutter step the delay so effective to
Ballmer another fine game tonight for
Murray's got it and Gallinari puts it in
beautiful fast by Murray
get down
[Music]
[Applause]
a little hop defensively twist his ankle
maybe when he tripped got it on the down
on the other end if I were just with the
basket
you don't Scott we're gonna see more you
can pick it up and he shoots a fadeaway
[Applause]
and he does the stop sit awhile ago
calling bunny rabbit cuz he's got
survives budget in that fight where'd it
come from
oh that's sweet son yeah it amazing how
the weak side rebound to just destroy
teams even it how good was that guy down
nice pass
[Applause]
in there together state you need to stop
pull that out he's got a shooter in the
corner but watch great pass better pass
then rate at the shot clock buzzer goes
in so it's a 10-point lead somebody
watch this Wow
Murray maneuvering tool in the clock
fadeaway good Jamal Murray over T
[Music]
[Applause]
came on this is the one right here
chanting both guys just got it right
there catch it in nine games we got 22
games 40 or more this year
Unchained now well so much for devin
booker x' blue arrow rua time a three
would give the nuggets the lead driving
in
[Applause]
pretty good defense pretty good hang
time by the youngster watch this if you
slap on that left arm the book in the
documentary thought it came out at all
good to be played on ESPN every so often
this is it kid a very good cop
[Applause]
for chasin em and they hand off now the
shot clock it to the mismanage I know
he did playing Dancing with the Stars
with Steven Adams and Down Goes Adams
[Applause]
three let's it go
he gets in and right away bluella how
does the quiver into the lane deflected
by yogurts
he'll get to ever again over a steal
again Shakalaka watch him when he
decides JJ sets Yogi's looking for
anybody give it to Murray
[Applause]
and we get a very purple dr1 the shoe
give all the
the flourish what a great awareness of
time steps up steps through is it out of
the hands yes it is five seconds to go
Marino's it got a hurry Murray Jamal for
three
[Applause]
sometimes on the early push that way you
find the defensive player retreating one
of three Los Angeles to to shoot
Marino's is let's go start he's got ten
points for the shoot he can go places
with that up and under Kent good
sometime
I'm like consider Millsap
[Applause]
take a shot there's his first one to
beat the buzzer
Jamal Murray staying outside wishing
mole inside he's trying to rest up
Murray around his man come on her knee
circus shot Murray with 22 big ones
from the position and here's is even
better Moe small guy gets the big guy
weak side help comes over that's what
Paul George back cut Murr
and Murray close it down it's a little
Authority a year ago it's 20 to 17 Jamal
Murray on a mission here bounce to
Murray Murray
throws it down right by Johnson Theresa
fine and then ready
[Music]
to go for the backboard still it just
gave this half court pass up seven push
mutters
the craziest we've ever seen Murray from
half-court nothing but Bank Russell he
chess Murray goes and gets it this
contestant three look what happened he's
a beauty
[Music]
you got a limb point lead now that first
time out and then out of the timeout
here comes a run Murray and knocks it in
Murray get Murray on Trent board of
shoes shot that's it good shot put the
ball mark Barton the yogic who throws it
high to Beasley five to shoot
hurry good look you know sometimes when
he's not thinking so much and he just
goes and does it
with defense that
[Applause]
in balance was it better Murray knocks
out that jump rate that was good defense
and off Murray like to see Murray get
going
by Knox and shoe oh yes he can
what am I talking about Jamal Murray now
8 seconds to go
buried around Baker we're through three
Nuggets 81 piston 62 you're watching
altitude sport five to shoot
Murray over the top
Jamal Murray pennies from heaven five
seconds
three for three yes
Jamal Murray
can you say Big Finish for the Denver
Nuggets bank halftime report is coming
up Marie one second let's say
[Applause]
step back over a 7-footer snake those
shots we gonna take those shots
alright the Nuggets lead at the break
5150 as Murray we're gonna show a couple
of replays of Murphy 9 on the board here
in the first half
Murray Ritter reverse layup with a point
five to go
what a great vote keep an eye on this
now watch how he navigates gets down
inside now I'm beyond the basket and I
still can play that back for me
[Applause]
this happened a quarter of his life and
maybe saving his teammates life together
[Applause]
easier more beautiful off more
passionate than going up and getting his
first playoff poster tomorrow Kaveri
who's got 22 points he draws cancer now
and the shot pocket three step back
Murray over cancer good it's a two
pointer and a two-point lead and this
guy is young Murray gets cancer again
the shot clock at two Murray drains it
and the lead is five for Denver
successful formula for the Nuggets
having Millsap post up shot clock down
to two up and over the backboard okay
what a way to get the scoring started
for the Nuggets as Jamal Murray with a
horse shot in the scoring till the
Nuggets here tonight boy just walking
the tightrope ow I mean he is way out
about the basket in for the jump shot
Murray a fakes at three kept his dribble
alive and throws it down wow what a play
watch up this is Murray going in and I
mean just such a dependable player every
night this league to do something
positive for your team
yo kids the rudder is good yeah just
past my breath Oh miss Cosby look nice
it can't be that easy and the hookers
just makes it beautiful what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content